[Music]
this morning on the dish
living high on the hogs the whole hog
that's the specialty of famed pit master
rodney scott already the recipient
of the prestigious james beard award
this year he was announced as an
inductee
into the barbecue hall of fame and he's
just
out with a new book rodney scott's world
of barbecue
he's got a restaurant in birmingham just
opened one in atlanta
and jamie wax caught up with him at the
place where it all began
it's early very early in the morning
here in charleston south carolina
and the smell of wood smoke perfumes the
air
rodney scott is busy supervising the
hive of imposing grills at what has
become a major destination for the
culinary art
that has made him internationally famous
whole hog barbecue i wish the people
watching this at home could smell this
place it's unbelievable
thank you it'd be smell-o-vision
[Laughter]
rodney scott has been cooking whole hog
barbecue since he was just 11 years old
yeah at his family's variety store
in the small south carolina town of
hemingway
from that time till now obviously you've
grown as a chef and a restaurateur
but has the process changed at all i am
definitely doing everything the exact
same way that i did it when i was 11.
it's just different equipment so i still
burn the wood down yeah still take the
hot coals and put it under the hog
and i still season the hog pretty much
the same way
i mean it's an obvious thing but but
when i read your description
of what whole hog really means as far as
flavor it makes a huge difference
because you've got
parts of the hog that are gamey or parts
that are fatty or parts are leaner and
you make
something brand new when you mix them
all together right yeah when you put
them all together you get
different bites from different areas of
the hall you know we describe
our barbecue as a difference you can
taste and what we mean by difference you
can taste is
you have ham you have loin you got belly
you got some shoulder and when all those
areas are combined
it adds up to one bite that can only be
described
as perfection all right that's very hot
all right
i'll try and pick a good piece okay i'm
gonna join you there
oh my god honestly best pork i've ever
tasted in my life
that's part of my technique to break it
up so the seasonings can go all the way
through it
and when you turn it over to pull it you
have everything in there you see that
it is true the salt the acid the smoke
it's all
perfect in that one bite but that one
bite was
only the beginning and he looked like he
had his legs crossed
i joined him for lunch surrounded by an
incredible spread of some of his most
popular dishes from his new book
rodney scott's world of barbecue it's
part cookbook
part autobiography there are worse jobs
than sitting
out in the south carolina breeze with
the master of carolina barbecue
and this beautiful table so all the
dishes on the table are pretty much
a layout of my life from the pulled pork
where it all started
grandma's cornbread what i remember from
being a kid
the ribs which i've come to love along
with the pulled pork
collard greens which i was a little
reluctant to eating but i do eat them
now
my mama's banana pudding and the dishes
that are
just introduced to me as a barbecue pit
master later on
was brisket looking at this layout of
his life
it's hard to forget that the road to pit
master started
at such a young age what is 11 year old
rodney scott like
11 year old rodney scott wanted to go to
a basketball game the work had to be
done before you went anywhere
this particular day it was a hog had to
be cooked and the challenge was laid out
you're going to cook this hog before you
go anywhere and i made sure not to burn
the hog
and when they flipped it over i was like
good you could pull the bone out like
it's supposed to it was done all over
woo i was like i think i can do this
others agreed in 2009 scott captured the
attention of a new york times food
writer
who wrote an article that changed his
life forever
people started to say hello and
strangers started to say hello
are you that guy from the new york times
and phone calls from different
newspapers and magazines started to
interact with us
and i thought it was huge the acclaim
led scott to finally accept the offer of
investor and restaurateur
nick pahakis he opened his own
restaurant in charleston
which led to another remarkable
achievement
they come in and they tell you you are
nominated for the james beard award
what did that mean to you at that time
when we got nominated for the beard
award it was
unbelievable to walk up on that stage
and look back out at all these great
chefs and these people in the food
industry
to be recognized as you know best chef
southeast was one of the most humbling
moments
i've ever experienced scott's growing
success
coupled with leaving the family business
worsened a long-existing rift between
him and his father
something he writes about with startling
frankness in his book
which was published shortly before his
father's death
i wish i could have had a real
conversation about why he was so opposed
to the things that i was doing that he
wanted to kick me out of the business
kick me out of the family too in this
book
you write an incredibly powerful
section about the relationship with your
father how did that come about and
what did it feel like to put that down
in writing this was years ago
that me and my dad did not agree on a
lot of things and in doing that
having that conversation for the first
time
to say i'm going to tell the world this
is what i experienced
was one of the moments that the tension
the
not sleeping well just kind of went away
because i felt like it's gone the load
is off my shoulders
letting go for scott has led to a sense
of gratitude for each day
it's the philosophy he literally wears
across his chest
every day is a good day i always say if
you're not in the obituary section you
got a good day
you know you got a chance to create the
mood
the feeling that you want to have
throughout that day you have an
opportunity
simply because you survived and beyond
just surviving
scott is also focused on what's next
what are you
most excited about looking at the future
of rodney scott
trying to spread our barbecue all over
the entire world
everywhere that's my goal
for cbs this morning saturday yeah
jamie wax yeah charleston
every day is a good day i love it look
at this in front of us pork ribs
greens collard greens collard greens
cornbread mac and cheese lemonade
little lemonade and look at this piece
of business yeah here can we get this
jamie learned from last time brought us
some food that's right he didn't bring
food he did
yeah dig in pulled pork sandwich yeah
good stuff
i'm gonna take a bite and try to eat
like michelle did the other week yes
right yeah